hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easyjet
wir sind heute in berlin in der easy
german summer school und durch die
heutige episode führt christina aus
ungarn und juval aus israel gemeinsam
mit mir mit mir unsere heutige frage ist
was für eine super kraft hättest du gern
los geht
was ist deine lieblings superkraft stell
dir vor du hättest eine super kraft
welche hättest du gerne die kraft der
liebe halt nicht gerne
und was ich hab sie auch aber ich hätte
sie gerne ganz und folge mich und was
würdest du mit dieser superkraft tun
dann zu einfach die ganze welt umarmen
wenn du eine superkraft hättest welche
wäre das
und sichtbar sein ähnlich und warum
mache ich das cool für welche superkraft
hättest du gern mit gemüse regen können
hatten warum man weiß ja was ich immer
mache cardus reizend oder nicht bevor
ich sie kaufe ja welche superkraft
hättest du gern gesund machen und warum
ich glaube das ist ziemlich praktisch
wenn man das kann ja ganz hälst du ein
interview und frage mich was in meiner
tasche ist welche superkraft ich wäre
gerne so wie ich wie bitte ich wäre
gerne so wie ich okay und weil ich finde
das ist super kraft genug unsichtbar
sein okay und weil das schon die zweite
frage ich würde gerne alle sprachen der
welt sprechen können ich hätte gern ganz
viel energie superkraft genau ich fand
zufrieden ist
ich würde mich gern bieten können und
weil ich gerne in null komma nix
irgendwo anders wäre die möglichkeit
gerne hätte irgendwas zu sein
und warum hast du jetzt nicht gesagt ich
würde gerne teleportieren können oder
ich würde gerne ich hätte gerne ganz
viel geld mit der kraft der liebe
brauchst du das nicht
ich bin zufrieden mit meinem leben ich
bin zufrieden so wie sie ist und ich
brauche eigentlich nicht mehr aus was
ich habe gedankenlesen wir irgendwie
cool wie so an ich manche will man ja
nicht unbedingt jahren aber so manche
leute nicht immer das sagen was sie
denken ist irgendwie läuft sogar ganz
lustig du möchtest gerne mit gemüse
reden können und das gemüse fragen
können ob es noch immer gut da es ist
wohl praktisch das ist eine sehr
bescheidene antwort versorgen täglichen
leben viel besser als und was anderes
wenn ich fliegen kann dann drehe ich
wahrscheinlich oben oder welche gedanken
diesen kann welche wahnsinnig aber ich
gemüse sprechen kannst kann ich auch
anwenden praktisch jeden tag
nach dem julianischen leute heilen will
dann wäre alles andere was ich sagen
kann ja sehr sehr selbstsüchtig aber ich
würde schon gerne fliegen können wohin
würdest du gerne fliegen ja einfach mal
so spaziert fliegen ja über die dächer
berlins ja aber was ist deine superkraft
ich bin netter typ
ok ich kann gut rappen weiß noch ich
kann gut drogen verkaufen
wow das ist super kraft schon weg
gemacht ich hätte auch unsichtbar gesagt
nicht mehr in die hose pinkelt eine
sprache die auf jeden fall noch fehlt
das türkisch bei meine ganze familie
meines mann meines vaters aus der türkei
kommt und ich es bis jetzt leider noch
nicht geschafft habe diese sprache zu
lernen körperliche energie körperliche
energie was würdest du damit machen
da würde ich viele dinge machen die ich
als nicht schaffe zu tun zum beispiel
zum beispiel viel sport machen schöne
sachen machen die mir spaß machen da hab
ich manchmal keine kraft ich habe zwar
im kopf habe ich die lust dazu aber der
körper sagt nein ich bin zu müde
ja ich würde glaube ich auch er gerne
fliegen können fliegen können weil alles
von oben betrachten zu können und auch
von a nach b schnell zu kommen
und woher möchtest luftschläge jetzt
gerade vielleicht in die karibik an den
strand mcb harry egal was du machst wir
machen party ok viel glück bei dem
sprach sprachkurs ja danke sehr
danke dass wobei ich natürlich auch
gerne fahrrad fahre aber das ist dann
eine sache der vergangenheit
okay vielleicht findest du ja auch so
etwas wie ein luftfahrzeug das könnte
ich mir gut vorstellen ja meinst du
nicht dass es dann kalt wird wenn du
oben in den lüften fließt ja im sommer
nicht mehr aber im winter da muss man
schon schal einpacken ja das stimmt aber
dass das geht ja vielleicht kannst du
mir helfen eine mütze zu stricken
und wenn du kranke menschen heilen könnt
ist kann ich auch arzt werden und auch
krankheiten die man sonst nicht heilen
kann man kann die wissenschaft gehen und
neue wege finden die pharmazie
weiterzuentwickeln
okay das klingt logisch und wenn du
unsichtbar sein könntest ja was bringt
mir doch eigentlich nicht so wirklich
viel und telepathie gedanken lesen
ich habe über ein wahnsinnig wenn man
jeden gedanken lesen kann der alle
weinen denkens doch das schlimmste noch
niemand für mich jetzt denke ich scheiße
aus michael ist immer so vor der scheiß
und wenn du dich in jede beliebige
person verwandeln könntest mir
eigentlich mit mir selbst ziemlich
ziemlich lieblos reicht wirklich zu sein
eine katze sein dass wir auch ganz cool
eine katze verwandelt sich auch noch
mehr als bei superkraft katzen kräfte
oder gemüse reden warum genau katzen
entspanntes leben aller zeiten
irgendwie 80 an einem tag schlafen und
hätte kai ligges gewissen nämlich den
garten gehen ein paar vögel umbringen
for you tube schleppen um nachher
abzuschrecken
vor gut gerade hat jemand gesagt die
kraft der liebe wäre seine lieblings
superkraft könntet ihr euch das auch
vorstellen was er damit gemeint hat ich
glaube also für mich persönlich ist das
keine superkraft sondern es gehört
irgendwie so dazu also vielen dank fürs
zuschauen
es war mal wieder eine folge von the
german jetzt wollen wir natürlich wie
immer auch von euch wissen was sind eure
superkräfte schreibt es in die
kommentare und christina was hat dir am
besten gefallen die frau mit dem energie
wunsch die frau mit dem energie und sie
wollte so viel energie haben und jubel
was hat dir denn besonders gut gefallen
heute ganze antworten waren sehr sehr
schön
wir haben mit viele lustige oder witzige
antworten bekommen und es gab einen mann
die mittige muss der mit gemüse sprachen
wollte und es war sehr sehr interessant
es war sehr kreativ auf jeden fall wenn
ihr lust habt bei uns bei der easy
german summer school mitzumachen
dann klickt auf den link und meldet euch
informiert euch wir würden euch hören
gerne von euch hören und spendet mit
papa trion wert unserer patria kumpanen
und an dieser stelle sage ich tschüs
beim und bis zum nächsten mal